last week I'd been away I came back to
Nottingham my colleagues were really
excited they'd seen a picture of a
molecule on the internet and it's really
rare you can see models and drawings and
molecules but actually see a picture
that somebody is measured that was
really something new when I was a
student it was believed that you could
never see molecules because if you use
an ordinary microscope the wavelength of
light is far too long you just can't see
atoms and all molecules you can use
so-called electron microscopes which
have a beam of electrons but those have
to be accelerated so fast to get a very
short wavelength that only the toughest
molecules can survive it's a bit like
hitting a molecule with a hammer and
only the tough ones will survive the
rest just get broken to pieces so you
can't really get pictures proper
pictures of atoms and molecules then in
about the late eighties scientists
realized that there's quite a different
way of looking at molecules rather like
the way that blind people read Braille
by feeling through their fingers so they
don't see the letters but they just feel
the bumps and so their idea was that if
you took a very sharp point and moved it
along the surface and came to a molecule
then you would feel a bump and you would
have to move it up to go over it and by
using a cunning system of lasers to
amplify the movement of this pointer you
could then see that there was a blob of
something on the surface and you can use
this quite nicely for large atoms
physicists at IBM's lab made a very
famous picture where they spelled the
word IBM or the letters IBM ads of atoms
of xenon on a cold surface and this has
become an iconic image the problem has
been
that the end of a tip that you can make
even if you make a very sharp metal tip
it's too fat to get the details of
molecule you can see it's much bigger
than the atoms in an ordinary molecule
now the breakthrough last week was that
some physicists again at IBM had the
idea of taking a molecule of carbon
monoxide oxygen and carbon which are
really the same size as atoms and
getting it to stick on the end of their
point their point then when they moved
it across they really could begin to see
the features of the atoms and what's
excited chemists their molecule had five
rings of carbon but also for the first
time ever you could get not really very
clear but a partly clear image of carbon
hydrogen bombs people have imagined what
molecules look like they've done
calculations they've made models out of
balls and States but it's really good to
know that it's what it looks like it's
like hearing somebody described over the
telephone and drawing their picture but
then to see that your identikit picture
really looks like the person is quite a
breakthrough and the same thing with
molecules the problem is that you can
only do these measurements if the
molecules are really very cold at very
low temperature so you can't see them
yet reacting because what would be
really nice would be to see molecules
banging together and actually reacting
one turning into another but we've got
to wait a bit of time before that can be
done there's molecules called pentacene
Penta is the Greek for five it has five
rings joined together why they chose
that I don't know except that it's a
nice big molecule and it has five
members of five rings with six carbon
atoms joined together in a row with
hydrogens attached and you can see these
five rings very clearly in the image
it would have been a better test if they
didn't know what the molecule was and
somebody had put it down and said do
your experiment and tell us how many
rings there are in this molecule but
when you're starting these things you
really need to know what the molecule is
so that you can check whether the
measurements you've made their
meaningful